against freddie peralta can't call him
fastball freddy anymore because he
throws more than just a fastball these
days he's throwing that slider quite a
bit about 50 50 these days which is
making it mostly difficult on opposing
hitters yeah that earned average seventh
best in the national league he's got the
98 strikeouts that's sixth best he
throws one right down the middle for
strikeout number 99 on the season mali
on the hill he has been particularly
great on the road well he's been really
good also his last few starts out there
on the road he's been really good and
that just shows you somebody who's
getting more and more confidence in
using all of his pitches dan vogel back
now held without a hit yesterday
and he lines this one into the gap in
left center naked trying to cut it off
he will but urease is going to streak to
third brewers have him on the corners
with nobody out and why not get
aggressive early in the count the fast
ball and hits it hard into center
christian yelich 1-2
swaying into this he struck him out now
that time the fastball was right on the
upper edge of the zone here is manny
pina basis loaded one out
and he smokes it to third caught on the
fly by freeman
he fills in at the hot corner and that's
a big second out the bases remain loaded
for jace peterson
struck him out fastball right down the
heart of the play two k's for mali and
he leaves him loaded
freeman in on the grass and charging
it is bunted up the first baseline
perfect bun for freddie peralta
and in scoring position on the sacrifice
now ureas with a two out rbi chance from
the lead off spot
swinging into this up and in with a
fastball he's got three k's and we have
a scoreless game kyle farmer leads off
the top of the third against freddie
peralta one two liner to left long run
yelich and he runs it down
1-2 pitch
struck him out
second strike out of the ball game and
number 100 on the season for freddie
peralta vogelback to lead off for the
crew
bogle back left center headed for the
gap extra bases daniel vogel back
speaking of igniting a rally vogel back
with his second hit of the game lead off
double and now the brewers with a real
threat here runner at second and nobody
out for christian yelich
line drive base hit
vogel back is going to be waved around
third the throw is going to go to second
it's one nothing milwaukee castiano's
gave up on that play didn't he bogoback
was content to go stop at third base
because he had to freeze he wasn't sure
if that ball was going to be caught
kind of surprised he was sent and
castillanos didn't even make a throw i
think if castiano's comes up throwing
they're going gonna hold him or
they might throw him out here's manny
pina with runners at first and second
base
swing and a miss he strikes out pena
peterson went down looking first time up
swinging a miss and it's back-to-back
case with a couple of men aboard that
half of an out away from an un otherwise
skate frame
fastball strike three three straight
strikeouts for tyler malley and he
strands a pair brewers push across the
game's first run nick castellano stands
and he popped to second his first time
up
nick castiano's nice back end maria is
the long throw off the bag vogelback of
the ball squirts free as he tried to tag
castionos through the bag
there goes the perfecto and the
no-hitter tyler naquin with a man aboard
fairly well struck
fairball
castiano's through second yelich gathers
wave is on yellow throw in the relay
no chance castellano slides home and the
reds tie the game
tyler
naked his fifth double in the last week
and a half what a great surprise it's
been for reds fans to watch naquin hit
and now here's joey votto
flailed at that fastball up and out of
the zone another strikeout for freddie
peralta his third reds do damage though
rbi double by naked now the pitcher
freddie peralta
and there he just catches the corner for
his seventh strike out of the game
louisa reyes the brewer leadoff hit her
standing in with nobody on and two out
swinging a miss
eight strikeouts for tyler malley one
off his season high and his first
perfect ending of the day farmers hit
safely in sixth straight as he bats here
in the
fifth
well-hit foul
i'm not sure how delano the shields got
out of the way that one bob nearly got
boxed
he's gonna have to hear about that
yes he
will finally got him change up for the
first time in this sequence carmilla is
wondering if he's going to break that
one out daniel vogelback leads off the
brewer 5th inning
swing and a miss a season high tying
nine strikeouts for tyler o'malley
christian yellage bats
swing in the miss double digit
strikeouts a new season high for maui
top of the order now jonathan india
got him there went back to the change up
tied him up a little bit off the inside
corner jesse winker has flied to center
and tapped one back to freddie peralta
winker
beats the shift for a base hit
yelich gotta hurry up winker trying for
two here's the throw
god of its second yelich had to hurry up
and get that one winker was
hunting a double there
he doesn't look very comfortable out
there at second base either valley is
retired nine in a row striking out seven
in that time
swing and a miss
ten in a row retired by mali a season
high 11 strikeouts ties for the most by
any red in a game this year if he gets
the next batter in tim lopes i'd run him
back out there for the seventh inning
swinging a miss a career high tying 12
strikeouts for a dominant tyler valley
tucker barnhart four for 12 a double and
a homer 3 33 bat against peralta mogul
back in front of otto
well hit opposite way fair ball votto
steams through second
yelich gathers wave is on yelich will be
challenged relay in bottle to the plate
the play he saved backside barnhart all
the way to third and the reds lead two
to one great big hitting by barnhart i
mean this is why he hits hitter pitchers
like peralta he's using the entire field
looks so much more comfortable being
only a lefty and the end of the play
right here oh yes he did get the plate
look at how fired up joey votto is lucas
sims is on red's pitching at a retired
17 straight spoiled by avisail garcia's
two out blue pit so lucas sims who got a
win last night bids for a four out save
sims cools them off
swing and miss as he chases off speed
down sims the k to strand a man willian
thomas with daniel robertson do next
adamus
down the left field line
it's a fair ball and it's into the
corner automatic double
willie adamus
check swing did he go
yes on appeal to first the reds aren't
out away from another sweep
the reds sweep the brewers
back to back sweeps
for cincinnati
eight straight road wins